- [Girish] Hello everyone.
My name is Girish, I'm a
senior solutions architect.
Along with me is my PSA Justin
and the two of us help AWS
customers move all the way
from ideation to production
with a special focus on AI ML.
Over the next 60 minutes, we are going
to learn a few things.
We'll kick things off here
by understanding four key concepts
that we are going to leverage
to build this agent factory.
From there, we'll move
to a coding terminal
and start creating some business agents
and then we'll interact with
the agent factory itself
to create some agents, multi-agent systems
on the fly for you. I want
you all to think about
one business agent that might be valuable
for your organizations. We are
going to take some requests
and try to create those
agents on demand here as well.
If you have any questions,
please raise your hand.
We'll try to take as many
questions as possible,
but given the time constraints,
if we aren't able to get to you,
we are absolutely going to stay back here
to address all your questions.
We are also going to be
sharing the code base with you.
So to get the most out of the session,
I recommend just thinking
about the why behind things
and you can clone the code
and you can try things yourself
at a later time as well.
So with that, let's get going here.
So our agent factory is going to have
what we call a builder agent.
What the builder agent does,
it'll take a request from a user
and then create either a single agent
or a multi-agent system on demand.
But what really is an AI
agent, I spoke to a few
of them here and still
there's some confusion
about AI agents, right? Everyone
has their own definition.
I think the simplest one that I've heard
is an agent runs a loop with a model
and with a set of tools
to take certain actions
to achieve a particular goal.
And to build these agents
require a framework.
In this case, we are going
to leverage the open source Strands SDK,
for three key reasons.
One, Strands makes it really
simple for us to create agents
with just a few lines of code
because it depends on the
intelligence of the frontier model
to create the code for us.
So instead of writing rigid logic trees,
it will do that work for us
and we tell it what agents to create.
Two, Strands comes with
its native set of tools.
So the most common tools
that an agent might require,
those are already built for you.
So we can directly start
tapping into those tools,
but it also makes it really simple for us
to create custom tools.
And three, Strands has
native support for some
of these immersion protocols.
So think of MCP and A2A
and our agent factor is going to use
those protocols as well.
But what really is MCP or
model context protocol?
So for our agent to
talk to different tools
and different data sources,
there needs to be a common
language between them
and that is exactly what MCP provides.
You can almost think of MCP
as a universal translator
where it provides a common
language for agents,
for tools and for data
sources to connect together
and work on things together.
But what if our agent factory
receives a request when it
needs to create a multi-agent system
where multiple agents
are talking to each other
and working together to
achieve a higher level goal?
And for that, we are going
to leverage what is known
as A2A or Agent2Agent
communication protocol.
A2A will provide us
three different things.
One, it allows an agent to
discover other agents around it.
Two, it allows an agent
to know the capabilities
of the agents around it so
it knows which agent to ask
for help whenever it's trying
to achieve a particular goal.
And three, it gives us a
common language for agents
to talk to other agents.
So despite of the models
or frameworks that different agents use,
there's a common language
in between that they can use
to communicate with each other.
Okay. So until now we
have learned three things.
One, our agent factory
will use the Strands SDK
to build agents. Two, it'll use MCP
for those agents to
connect to different tools
and to connect to different data sources.
And three, our agents will
use A2A to connect and talk
to other agents for more complex goals.
But how can we take our agent factory
from a prototyping environment
all the way to production?
And for that, we are going
to tap into AgentCore,
which is a purpose built service
for running agent systems
at scale, securely
and in an operationally efficient manner.
It provides us with a
set of modular services
that we can pick and choose
from based on the requirements
of a particular agent.
And this might really
look like a busy slide,
but let's think this
through together, right?
Whenever our agent factory
receives a request,
it needs to deploy those agents
and run those agents somewhere.
So what does the agent
factory need for that?
One, it needs a place
where it can run the agents
in a secure environment,
ideally serverless,
we don't want to manage the
infrastructure ourselves,
but there could be situations
where an agent needs like three minutes
to complete a particular task.
But there could be like long
running agents which require
like five hours to run, right?
And so this serverless
runtime should support
like small term tasks as
well as long term tasks.
And that is exactly what
the AgentCore Runtime
will provide us. But once we move things
from a prototyping
environment to production,
like security will become
even more important.
And for that we are going
to tap into what we call
as the identity feature,
which will do a couple of things for us.
One, it'll ensure that only
the users who are supposed
to have access to our agents,
only those users can access the agents.
And two, the agents
themselves can only access
the tools that they're supposed to,
can only access other agents
that they are supposed to.
All agents are only going to be as smart
as the things they can remember.
And for that we are going
to use the short-term memory
and long-term memory provided
by AgentCore memory feature.
For some agents which require
to write their own code
to execute that code as well,
we are going to leverage
the AgentCore code interpreter feature
and there might be some agents which
need to browse the internet,
go on the internet, fill web forms for us.
For that we could use the
browser tool which provides us
a really secure environment
to access internet at scale.
One of the key features
or of our agent factory is
going to be what is known
as an AgentCore Gateway.
It does a couple of things for us.
AgentCore Gateway allows us
to have existing Lambda
functions or new Lambda functions
and expose them as if they
were MCP tools for our agents.
So say for example, our agents
now can connect to a gateway
and the gateway talks to Lambda functions
or APIs so that we don't
need to manage those APIs
or create MCP servers ourselves.
The gateway will expose them
as if they were NCP servers for us.
And finally, to make sense of everything,
to know why a particular
agent did a particular thing
or to know how to troubleshoot issues,
we are going to tap into
the observability feature
of AgentCore. Okay.
So now we know we are going
to have a builder agent.
Its role is just one thing,
takes users requests,
creates an agent or a
multi-agent system for us,
this builder agent is built using Strands,
is deployed on AgentCore
as the infrastructure.
The builder agent will have
access to three different tools,
one tool to create Lambda
functions. So these are the tools
that our agents will use to take action.
The second thing it does
is it has the ability
to create gateways on the fly
and to associate those lambda functions
with the gateway as MCP servers.
And thirdly, it can create and
deploy the agents themselves.
So once it deploys these agents,
these agents will work within
the AgentCore environment.
It'll access different tools
like Slack, Salesforce,
or any custom tools that you
might have across the gateway.
And that is how the
agent factory will work.
Okay. So now that we
know a little bit more
about the agent factory,
let's move to coding here.
If you can just turn it on.
(indistinct)
Can you all confirm
that it is large enough
for you all to see?
- [Audience] Yes. Yes.
- [Girish] Okay, cool.
So the very first thing
that I want to show you all
is a simple chat bot, right?
What I'm trying to show you
is how easy it is for us
to create these chat bots
or agents using Strands.
To create a chat bot with Strands,
we need just three lines of code.
One, I will import the
agent class from Strands.
Two, I'll then create an agent function
and three, I just trigger
that particular function,
ask it what re:Invent is.
And as you can see, it
came back with an answer.
So that is the power of Strands.
Like it just takes you a few lines of code
to create an agent and to
deploy that agent as well.
But there'll be times
when we need to select
a particular model,
right? In the first case,
what happened was we used
the base, the default model.
In that case it'll use Claude Sonnet 4.0.
But if I wanted to use a particle model,
all that I need to do is I
will import Bedrock model
from Strands. That is the difference.
Two, I'll mention what the model ID is.
So in this case you can see
the model ID is Nova Premier,
but tomorrow, say for
example if I wanted to use
Llama, right, from Meta, all that I do
is I change the model ID
here to Llama and run this.
It gives me the ability
to control randomness
or the behavior of the model
in terms of temperature
and top P as well
as if it's a chat based
application, right?
You can enable streaming for it.
But say for example, tomorrow,
OpenAI creates a new model,
an open source model, and we wanted
to leverage that model, right?
All that I do is I switch the model ID,
the rest of the agent code
stays exactly the same.
So this gives you a lot of flexibility.
Tomorrow, whenever new
models come into the picture,
you can keep the same agent code.
All that you do is switch the model ID.
We are also going to be providing
you three different files.
So if there are situations
where you want to consume
a model directly from
Anthropic as the provider,
so Anthropic provides
models on Bedrock of course,
but if you wanted to
consume it from Anthropic,
that's an option on Strands as well.
If you wanted to consume a
model directly from OpenAI,
it supports that as well.
And for some situations, if you
wanted to run a local model,
it supports Ollama.
So you can run a model
within your environment,
instead of running it on the cloud.
But like we discussed, a
true agent is what has access
to model as well as a set of tools
to take action on our behalf.
And now we'll start
interacting with agent tools.
The first thing, what
I'm going to do here is
I want to show you, say for
example our agent factory
got a request to create an agent
which can browse the internet,
find what AWS released last week,
create a news briefing of it,
and then upload it onto an S3 bucket.
So the difference in this
case is I'm going to import
some tools from Strands.
Strands provides a set
of various tools and we
will give you access to
our different tools it
supports out of the box.
But http_request will allow
it to access the internet,
use_aws will give it the ability to use
Boto3 libraries so that it can interact
with our AWS environment and current_time
gives it an understanding of
what date and time it is today.
So it goes back a week and
finds what AWS released.
From there, I am using
Anthropic as the model ID
in this case for creating the agent.
I'm giving it a system prompt where I say,
"Hey, you are a news anchor
specializing in finding AWS news
and going to the internet
and then finding the news,
creating a news summary of it,
and then uploading it onto an S3 bucket."
So that is my system prompt.
The difference here is
the tools that I imported.
I'm telling it to use those
tools for doing those things
and then invoke it, right?
Like, "Hey, what's the latest AWS news?"
So now the agent is able
to understand the request,
take action on our behalf.
So what you can see is
it first use the current time tool,
then it use the http_request
to find the latest
AWS announcements.
And then it is using the
use_aws tool to upload that
to S3 on my behalf. And here
it is taking my permission,
there's ways for us to
automate that as well.
But I'm saying, "Hey, it's
okay for you to go ahead
and create this put_object request."
I say yes to it. And now
if I go to my S3 bucket
and refresh this, you will
see it has created a new file
and it created a news briefing for us.
So that is the power of agents
that can take action on our behalf.
This could have been something
which is more logical
to your business with a key
thing here is give it access
to a model, a set of tools
and let them do the work
on our behalf. Okay.
So the next thing I want to show here is
what if our agent factory
receives a request
wherein it not just needs
to create new agents,
but it also needs to create custom tools
outside of what Strands provides,
but build those tools on the fly based on
what the user request is.
So what I'm doing here is I've
created an agent which can
create different tools for
me. I just ran that agent.
I'm going to ask it to create a tool
that can calculate compound
interest as an example.
And let's go through the
code here for a minute.
The only difference here than
the previous thing is one,
I'm importing editor from Strands.
This will let it write code
and execute code on our behalf.
And then I'm telling it, "Hey, go ahead
and create new tools,
add those tools within
a particular directory,
the tools directory, but
also hot-load those tools
so that I can start using
those tools immediately.
So again, it went ahead, it is now asking
for my permission here to
make a right operation within
that particular tools directory.
So let me open that tool,
compound interest tool.
So this is very similar
tool or Python function.
Yeah, please go ahead.
- [Attendee 1] So here, (indistinct).
- [Host] So the question
I can repeat it is,
we're running these tools locally,
generating these tools locally
and then if we were to
deploy this to AgentCore,
how might we create those tools Girish?
- [Girish] Great. So that is
going to be the next phase.
So what we are doing here is
running and creating these tools locally.
The next phase is going
to move it from our local
environments to AgentCore
and it'll use the same logic there.
So our agent factory takes a request,
it creates a particular tool
or a set of different tools,
then it creates a gateway,
associates those tools with the gateway
and then it creates an agent
to give it access to those tools.
So that will be the next
thing we'll do here today.
Does that help you?
(indistinct)
Okay, any other question?
Okay. So as you can see,
it went ahead and
created this tool for us.
The only difference is
the @tool decorator.
Everything else is just a Python function.
So that is the power of Strands.
You can have your existing
or new Python functions
and expose them as tools
with the @tool decorator
that your agents can use to
take action on your behalf.
So if I now go ahead and ask it to
calculate the compound
interest as an example,
it knows it has a set of
three different tools.
It identifies the right tool
to calculate the compound
interest and then it goes ahead
and calculates that on our behalf as well.
This is not a meta-tooling.
We are going to use this
concept within the agent factory
where it can create other agents
and other tools on the fly.
Okay. So the next thing I
want to show you all here is
what if our agent was required
to access MCP servers?
So the example that I'm using here is
I'm creating almost a solutions architect.
What it'll do is it'll have access
to the latest AWS documentation.
So if something was launched yesterday,
it is within the documentation,
it needs to go ahead
and find what that thing
is in the documentation
and then I'm going to give it a request
to calculate the total cost
of ownership for hosting
that thing on AWS. To
keep things simple here
I'm creating a static
website and I'm telling it,
"Hey host this on S3, have
a cloud front in front of it
and tell me how much it would
cost me to host this on AWS.
So the difference here is that
I'm going to make this agent
as an MCP client so that it can access
different MCP servers.
Two, I'm giving it access
to read and write files
because I'm asking it to
create the TCO calculations
and save that file on my local machine.
And three, I'm making
an STDIO client as well
so it can interact with those MCP servers
from my local machine.
I'm also giving it access
to certain access keys.
And that is only because
the pricing MCP calculator
requires access keys access.
But that is not always the case.
Everything else pretty much stay the same.
I'm giving it the role here in the prompt.
"Hey, you are an SA. You can write files,
you can read files,
you can find the documentation
of different things
and then you can go ahead
and serve the user's request.
So in this case, let us see
what it did behind the scenes.
So the first thing that it does is
it installs different MCP servers.
Then it finds the different tools
that those MCP servers provide.
So read documentation,
source documentation,
get pricing information, then it finds...
Then it actually takes the action, right?
So it is now finding the
pricing for different things.
It is finding the documentation
for different things if
it runs into an error.
So in this case it wasn't
able to find data transfer
as the pricing code,
it'll self-correct itself
and it found the right
code and it went ahead,
took my permission, "Hey, can I go ahead
and write this file?" I said yes.
And now I see a new file being created
which has the TCO calculation
of hosting a static website
along with links to those documentations.
So this is how you can create MCP clients
and have your agents work with MCP tools.
I see a question there.
- [Attendee 2] Yes. So
when the MCP interaction
with the cloud and server,
how does it manage the context window?
What if the tool in terms
of all (indistinct),
how does it manage the context window
so that it doesn't blow up the LLM?
- [Host] Did you get
that question, Girish?
So the question was how do you manage
the context window coming
back from the MCP tool?
- [Girish] Mm. So within Strands,
like we have provided functionality
where it knows how to manage
the context with MCP servers.
So you don't need to
create that logic yourself.
All that you do is you
create the MCP client,
give it access to different
MCP servers that you want
and then it will take
the right information.
Like we have added, say for example,
limits in terms of how much it can access,
what it can access, so it does not flood
your context window. So you
don't really need to spend a lot
of time on managing it.
That logic is built into it
and it can do that on your behalf.
Go ahead.
(indistinct)
Yes. Let me do that now.
- [Attendee 3] Because I
did see that you gave us
an explanation of (indistinct).
- [Girish] Mm.
(indistinct)
- [Attendee 3] You give the
documentation (indistinct).
- [Girish] Mm.
- [Attendee 3] So why was this
web server (indistinct)?
- [Girish] Great.
So in this case, can
you repeat the question?
- [Host] Yeah, I think
the question is about
the tool documentation that
you provided in the code
versus that living in the MCP server.
- [Girish] Great. So
the difference is one,
like it needs access to the
latest documentation, right?
So instead of using... So think
of tools more to take action
versus MCP, in this case
we'll give it access
to the latest documentation.
If we tap into the MCP server
for documentation, there's
another MCP server for pricing.
So rather than creating
those tools yourselves,
we have built those MCP servers for you
so that you can start consuming them.
So there's an MCP server
for taking API action,
there's an MCP server for pricing.
Different services have
their own MCP server.
So based on the agent,
what it needs to do,
you can give it access
to the right MCP server
and it can interact with
it, find what's the latest.
You don't need to manage those.
You just create the agent
and have the agent interact with it.
- [Host] Okay, we'll take some more
questions after the session.
I think we need to make sure
we're continue moving forward.
- [Girish] Just hold
onto it. We'll get back.
- [Host] Yeah, we'll come back to you.
- [Girish] So the
difference in this case is
I created those MCP clients. I told it,
"Hey, connect to the pricing server
as well as the MCP server."
And this agent is now able to do that.
But what if I wanted to
create a multi-agent system
which can have multiple
agents working together,
which could be a common requirement
for your agent factory, right?
So in this case, what I'm going to do
is let me show you the
architecture for it.
I'm creating an HR system.
It will take a user's request,
I'm asking it to host an HR
agent locally on port 8,000.
It talks using A2A to an
employee agent on port 8,001
and it uses an MCP server to get,
it's almost like a database,
to get employee data.
The request that I'm going to make it is
can you find me which employees
can help me on a particular
machine learning project?
I've given it a database
of different employee needs
with different skill sets
and it needs to identify who
those right employees are.
So I'll make a call request
here to trigger the HR agent.
Let me go ahead and do that.
And while it does that, let
me show you what the code is.
So for the HR agent, I'm
making it an A2A client.
So I import the A2A client provider.
I tell it this is the URL
that you are supposed to be hosted on.
For the employee agent,
this is an A2A server.
So I'm importing A2A server instead.
I give it the URL it's hosted on
as well as I tell like,
"Hey, this is the MCP server
URL that you have access to."
And this is just some Python
file that I've created
to replicate a database.
These are the first names of employees,
these are the last names
and these are the different skill sets
that those employees have, right?
So let us go ahead and see
what the call request did.
It sent a request to our server,
it found what different employees
have different skill sets
and then it recommends, "Hey, based on
what machine learning requires,
the frameworks and the technologies,
like these are the set of employees."
Which are the right employees
for us to work with.
Okay. So the final thing
now I'm going to show
is taking this to AgentCore now.
So I'm going to deploy this
particular server to AgentCore
and let me go ahead and do that.
So I've installed the
AgentCore CLI, I'll have it...
I'll have it deploy to agent call for us.
- [Host] Do you ever
get nervous with someone
looking over your shoulder as you type?
(Girish laughs)
Girish is feeling that
right now
- [Girish] Yeah.
- [Host] Times about 100.
- [Girish] Okay. AgentCore configure,
this E... And I'm giving
it that agent's file.
I'll show you that file as well.
Okay. So what this will do is it'll ask us
what we want to name the
agent. Let's call it HR agent.
It's asking what requirements
to put into that particular agent.
I have given it a requirements file.
I give it what Python version to utilize,
what is the execution role. I
just use the defaults for it.
And then it is asking me if
I want to give it a memory,
I give it memory as well
and I go ahead and launch this thing.
Okay. So what should happen now is
it will go to the AgentCore
file that we have created.
The only difference between
a local Strands Agent
and AgentCore is three different things.
One, I import the AgentCore app.
Two, I create the
AgentCore app, I define it.
And three, what I do is, I
put in the @app decorator.
So this is what my entry
point of the agent is.
So whenever someone triggers that agent,
this is the core that
it is supposed to run.
Everything else that we have
been creating with Strands
stays exactly the same.
Okay, so now let me move
back to the terminal
and show you what it is doing.
So what it does is it's
creating the AgentCore.
Runtime here, it created
different roles for us,
it created memory for us.
And this can take a couple of minutes.
It is creating, uploading things onto S3
after it's created the role
and now it is launching
things to AgentCore.
And this is exactly what
our agent factory is going
to utilize as well.
So to see all these
things being automated,
let's move on to the agent factory
and we can show these things in action,
how we can automatically create
and do all this work
without writing that code.
And for that, let me
pass on to Justin here.
- [Justin] Okay, great.
Well thank you Girish.
So just to recap what we just saw,
we saw a lot of stuff, right?
We saw things like Strands
and how you can use Strands
SDK to build agents.
We saw MCP servers and
how you can configure MCPs
on those Strands Agents. We saw A2A
and how you can configure
a multi-agent system using
A2A clients and A2A servers.
And then the very last thing we saw was
how can we actually take all this
and deploy it to
production using AgentCore?
Now we have to ask ourselves the question
and that question is, is there
an easier way to do all this?
Girish just wrote a ton of code,
he wrote it ahead of time obviously,
but ran through a bunch of code.
It's a ton of work to still
create all these Strands Agents,
create all of these different tools.
And is there an easier
way, is there a way for us
to maybe use an agent
factory or a builder agent
that we could speak to in natural language
and that agent could build
agents for us on the fly
from scratch according to our requirements
and then deploy them securely and scalably
into AgentCore Runtime?
And that's what we're
gonna take a look at now.
So Girish and I are gonna do
a little bit of role playing
and I'm gonna play the role
of the company AI guru.
So I'm the guy that everyone
comes to to build their agents
and I'm always up late, working at night,
getting these random requests from people
to build them some
random agent to help them
with their business task at work.
Alright, so it's a late Friday night,
I'm ready to get off of
work, I'm super tired
and suddenly I get a call from Girish.
- [Girish] Hi Justin, I know
this is late Friday night.
I have one last request for you.
We have a really board
meeting on Monday morning.
Can you please create an
agent which can help us make
investment decisions within
different industries?
I promise this is the
last thing I have for you.
- [Justin] Sounds good, Girish.
Alright, so it's 7:00 PM on a Friday.
I want to go hang out with my friends,
but now I need to make a decision.
Am I gonna build an agent
from scratch using Strands
and AgentCore and do all of
this coding and programming?
Or am I gonna use an agent
factory to help automate a lot of
that process and deploy that agent for me?
And so I'm gonna pick the second option
so I can go to sleep
at some point tonight.
So what I built here is just a
really simple CLI application
that we can use to interact
with our builder agent.
And that's what we're gonna call it.
Our builder agent is kind of
the key to our agent factory.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and just type in one here
and I'm gonna kick off a agent creation.
I'm gonna just say, "Create
me an agent that can perform
risk analysis using a tool to determine
risk by industry vertical."
(keyboard clicking)
And we'll kick this off now
the builder agent's gonna be
thinking here, it's gonna be
doing things like crafting
this system prompt for this agent.
It's going to be building that
tool that it needs to do any
of the business logic
and then deploying all of
that to AgentCore. So while this runs,
rather than just stare at the screen,
let's go ahead and take a look at some
of the code under the hood
of what's actually happening here.
And we're gonna make all of
this code available to you
after the session. But just
to take a look together,
I'm gonna go into the builder agent folder
and this is sort of the
heart of the project,
which is this builder_agent.py file.
So let make this a little bit
bigger for everyone to see.
And our builder agent is gonna use a lot
of those same core concepts
that Girish mentioned.
So things like Strands, we're
importing agents and tools.
And so if I scroll down here,
we're gonna see our app entry point.
So this builder agent
is already been deployed
to AgentCore Runtime.
And so we've got our app entry point here
so we know which function to invoke
when this agent is called.
Scrolling down here a little bit,
going through all of this
various payload handling,
we'll get to the real logic
and meat of this function.
We've got our model
initialized, we have our memory.
So our builder agent is gonna have
just a small snippet of code
here starting on line 78
for our memory hook.
And this is gonna give it
access to short-term memory
with a history of five.
So it's gonna have those
five previous messages
automatically loaded in when you
chat with the builder agent.
Additionally, here's our
Strands agent configuration
starting on line 87.
And you'll notice there's
about six tools here
and there's three of them
that are really important
that I wanna call your attention to.
And those three are
deploy_agents, create_gateway
and create_lambda_tools.
So our builder agent is
going to use all three
of these different tools to automate
that agent creation process.
The first thing that it will
do is call create_gateway.
And this is gonna create an
AgentCore Gateway for us,
which serves as sort
of like a facade layer.
Girish mentioned this during
some of those initial talks.
It's a facade layer that
allows your agent to connect
to things like Lambda
functions or other APIs
over MCP protocol. So the
first thing it will do
is create that gateway,
then it will create those lambda tools.
So in this case for our risk
agent that's running right now
and behind the scenes,
it's gonna create one tool
that's gonna deploy to Lambda
that will be exposed via
that AgentCore Gateway.
And then finally it's
going to deploy the agent
to AgentCore Runtime using
this deploy_agent tool.
Alright, we have our system prompt here,
we'll take a look at that here in a moment
and then we just pass back a response.
So pretty, pretty
straightforward code here.
So let's go back to our terminal
and we're gonna see, hey, great,
our risk agent's been
successfully created,
it's been deployed, it's
called risk analysis agent
and here's the associated gateway.
So why don't we give
this risk agent a try?
So I'm gonna go ahead and test it out.
So I'm gonna using my agent factory,
go to chat with deployed
agents, which is option two.
Give this a minute to
load. It's gonna pull back
all of the available agents
that are have been deployed
to the agent factory.
And here we can see Girish's
HR agent from earlier
and then my brand new risk analysis agent.
So we'll chat with that
risk analysis agent
and we'll say what is
the risk associated with
the technology industry?
(keyboard clicking)
And while this runs, why
don't we take a look at some
of the infrastructure that was
deployed by our builder agent
to make this risk analysis agent possible.
So I go to my console here
and I go to Bedrock AgentCore Runtime.
I'm gonna see this freshly
deployed risk analysis agent.
I'm also gonna go to gateways
and here I'm gonna see
a risk analysis gateway.
So this is that sort of
extra layer that we added in
to allow us to expose Lambda functions
to our agent as tools.
And then if I click in here under Targets,
I see we've got this risk analysis target
that's actually a brand
new lambda function
that our builder agent
deployed for us on the fly.
So this risk analysis function,
it's gonna be mostly
just generic logic here,
but you can easily think
of the possibilities
if you have, go into more detail
and you wanna connect to some
sort of third party system,
the builder agent could easily
write that kind of logic
and deploy it as a lambda function,
which you could then expose
to your agent as a tool.
Alright, perfect. So I'm gonna
go back to the console here
and here we can see our
technology industry risk analysis
of a score of 70/100.
So this is just some generic
response back from our agent.
Alright, Girish,
(Girish laughs)
we created our technology
risk assessment agent
and I'm ready to go to
bed now at this point.
- [Girish] No, I think
this looks amazing Justin,
thank you for it. And
thinking we could also connect
this risk agent to different
third party systems as well
as our own intelligence systems.
But I have one final thing for you,
I promise this is the final request.
- [Justin] All right,
hit me with it. (laughs)
- [Girish] We have a set of
interns coming on Monday,
they are going to be
traveling to different places
to get training. Can we create
an agent which can help them
expense things when they travel?
I promise this is the last request.
- [Justin] Sure, yeah, I'll give it a try
with our agent factory.
So let's go back to our builder agent here
and let's ask for, you know,
"Create me an expense agent
that can fetch expenses by
user and add new expenses."
(keyboard clicking)
And we'll kick this off.
So this is gonna be great Girish
'cause right now I know we're tracking all
of our interns expenses
just on an Excel sheet
and it would be great if we
had an agent that we could use
to, you know, maybe update
some kind of backend data store
to allow our interns to
easily add new expenses
or view their existing expenses.
So we'll give our builder
agent here a minute
to create this expense.
And while this is running,
let's just go ahead
and take a look at the system
prompt of our builder agent.
So we talked about these
three important tools
and again, we'll publish this code
so you can take a look at
what's happening under the hood
for these different tools.
But we also have our system prompts.
Those are super important
to take a look at.
So for our builder agent system prompt,
we've got some rules like
only create one gateway,
only create one agent.
We don't wanna have any
kind of duplications,
which can certainly
happen when you're running
an agentic loop, it could
sometimes duplicate efforts.
So we just make sure we include
these as critical rules.
And then we've got a couple options here.
If it's a simple agent that
doesn't require a tool,
it's just gonna deploy
an agent with no gateway.
And then option two, which is
what we've been using so far,
is create an agent with custom tools.
So I mentioned this previously,
but the first step is to create
that gateway in AgentCore,
then we create our Lambda tools.
So it's basically writing
lambda functions from scratch
and deploying those and then it's going
to deploy the agent right here.
After step three you're done,
agents created successfully and then stop.
So we don't have any
kind of duplicates set
that might occur.
Alright, so going back to the terminal,
we can see our expense
agent is now deployed.
So let's give it a quick test
before going back to Girish
with our finished product.
Go to our expense agent and
say, "What is user001 expenses?"
(keyboard clicking)
- [Girish] So Justin, like when you are
asking this question,
where does it come back
with an answer from?
Is this data now stored somewhere?
- [Justin] That's right, Girish.
So actually we exposed
our builder agent to a set
of DynamoDB tables that we have...
- [Girish] Mm-hm.
- [Justin] That are
storing these expenses.
So our builder agent's intelligent enough
to recognize those data sources
and then write the
corresponding business logic
in the lambda functions to
connect to those data sources.
- [Girish] Wow.
- [Justin] All right, so
here we've got our expenses
for user one and we can
see we've got some coffee
and Starbucks expenses, et cetera.
Probably hanging out at re:Invent
and getting some coffee,
these interns. Alright cool, Garish,
we've got the expense agent completed.
At this point I'm turning
my phone on silent.
(Girish laughs)
I don't wanna hear from you anymore.
I'm gonna go enjoy my Friday night.
But if anybody in the
crowd has a example agent
they'd like me to create, let's
go ahead and give it a shot.
Just raise your hand.
(indistinct)
- [Girish] Okay.
Right, data source. Hmm.
Yeah, so Justin, the question is we showed
how the agent can connect
to the right Dynamo table.
Like how does it understand the logic
to identify the right sources
when you create the new agent
and how is it able to
intelligently say connect
to this DynamoDB table?
- [Justin] Got it. Yeah,
so a lot of that's gonna be
provided as context to the agent.
So you can do that a couple of ways.
You can either include
that in your system prompt,
is like, "Hey, these are
your available data sources
and this is the schema that you can use
to connect to these data sources."
Or you can expose your agent
to some sort of MCP tool,
I know AWS does publish quite
a few different MCP tools
that you could use, which your
builder agent in this case
could use to search through
your AWS infrastructure,
identify those relevant data sources.
- [Girish] So they use
AWS tool that we had seen
before that will give it
access to all Boto3 libraries.
So it can go in their account,
find what data sources are there
and it can connect to
those data sources as well.
(indistinct)
Hmm. Mm.
Hmm. Great.
(indistinct)
Great.
Hmm. Yeah.
So usually within
production you would want
to have it within your context
so that it limits itself
to just those tools and you define like,
"Hey this is a Dynamo table for expenses,
this is a Dynamo table for
summoning PTO requests,
so on and so forth.
But like you could give it
the intelligence in like
a non-production environment
where you can let it
figure it out itself. But in
production what we have done
is we have created the
system prompt and told it,
"Hey, this table is for
submitting expenses,
this table is for doing X, Y, Z."
So it knows what to use.
(indistinct)
Mm.
Yeah.
(indistinct)
We'll take that one after a few examples
just for the sake of time.
But yeah, we will get
to it as well. Any...
- [Justin] So if anyone
has an example agent
they want us to create...
- [Girish] Do you want us
to create an agent, yeah.
- [Justin] Raise hand do agent?
- [Girish] Go ahead.
- [Attendee 5] The same example,
that was posted earlier,
multi-agent example.
- [Girish] Hmm.
- [Justin] Yes. Alright,
why don't we go ahead
and show that. So
Girish, I know we created
our expense agent.
- [Girish] Okay.
- [Justin] Right. Well, I know our interns
also need to take PTO.
- [Girish] Mm.
- [Justin] So what if
we create a PTO agent
that lets 'em do something very similar?
- [Girish] Okay.
- [Justin] And then after that
my thought is we can create some sort
of multi-agent system
using our agent factory
with an orchestrator that the
interns could interact with.
- [Girish] Mm-hm.
- [Justin] And then be able
to interact with the
expense agent, our PTO agent
and then any other new agents we decide
to build in the future.
How does that sound?
- [Girish] Sounds great.
Yeah.
- [Justin] Alright,
let's go ahead and give that a shot.
So similarly to our expense
agent, let's go ahead
and prompt our builder
agent here to say, you know,
"Create me a PTO agent
that can fetch PTO by user
(keyboard clicking)
and you know, submit new PTO requests."
(keyboard clicking continues)
Alright, so this is gonna
create that PTO agent.
I'm just creating two
sample agents here just
to demonstrate A2A and then
we'll create an orchestrator
here in a moment.
Alright, so we'll give this
a moment to think, question.
- [Attendee 6] So in this case,
is it like one of the tools essentially,
does it require like an API
integration with whatever,
you know, internal PeopleSoft
application is used
to manage PTO or are we assuming
that PTOs being managed by,
you know, Excel file for these interns
or some other data source?
- [Justin] Right. Yeah,
it could do either.
So if you have some sort
of external third party,
as long as you specify that or give
your builder agent context of that system,
it can write the lambda code on the fly
to connect to that system right as a tool
and expose that tool to your agent.
- [Girish] Yeah, so just
to repeat the question,
the question was in case
if we have our system,
like the PTO system being
managed by SoftChoice,
which is a third party tool,
can we give agents access
to those tools as well to
manage it there instead
of DynamoDB that we are
doing here, all right.
So absolutely, all that you would do
is the Lambda function
would have the logic
to connect to those tools as MCP servers
and then your agent connects
to the gateway which talks
to Lambda, which connects to people
or SoftChoice for example,
to manage that as well.
So it can, like in the diagram
we showed like connecting
to Slack and Quip like it can connect
to third parties as well,
- [Host] Right.
- [Justin] Okay. Okay. So
right now our PTO agent's
being assembled under the hood
and then I also wanna just
show our generic agent code.
So we looked through the
builder agent, which is a lot
of the business logic of
what's actually being created,
but we also have to deploy an agent.
And so that's where we, what
we call our generic_agent.py.
So really this is a
pretty basic Strands Agent
and then we're passing
a lot of these different
environment variables like the
model ID, the system prompt,
the gateway ID if it needs
to connect any kind of tools
in as an environment
variables to this code.
And then deploying this as those
separate different runtime,
those runtime agents that
get deployed to AgentCore.
So just to walk through
this code briefly here,
we've got one function
here to construct A2A URLs.
So for multi-agent systems, we need
to have this function onboard so
that way our agents can
discover each other using A2A,
and this is the URL that we're returning
on Bedrock AgentCore, we have
this create agent function
that I'm going to skip here,
but we'll take a look at it momentarily.
And then we have our main function.
So if you remember from
Girish's presentation,
he mentioned four A2A, there's such things
as A2A servers and A2A clients.
Now an A2A server, for the
most part all of our agents
so far that we've created
have been a to a servers
or the agent mode of server.
And so this block of code's going to run
or we create that agent,
we expose this runtime URL,
and then we run this
command here of A2A server,
which is gonna host this at port 9,000.
And this makes this agent
viewable and exposed
to any sort of A2A clients
that might be on our network.
And I'm gonna scroll down here,
we're just doing some basic,
you know, mounting here of the server.
And then in our else
statement, this is client mode.
So if we deploy any orchestrators,
any orchestrator agents,
those are are deemed as clients
and here we're gonna do
some of that standard stuff
that Girish did earlier
with BedrockAgentCoreApp,
we run this app command and
then we specify our entry point
in the invoke agent command
and here we just run our
create_agent function
and create an A2A client.
Okay, perfect. And then
our create agent function,
this is where a lot of
that business logic is.
So we've got some if statements,
if we need code interpreter,
let's add this code interpreter tool.
If we need browser, let's
add our browser tool.
If our agent mode is client,
here's our setup for A2A
so it can discover those other A2A agents
that are on the network as A2A servers.
And so here's some
boilerplate code here around
A2A client tool provider.
So this gives it access to
those standard A2A tools
that it would need to
discover agents over A2A
and then also send those agents messages.
And then we've got our gateway ID.
So if we do have a gateway, we
need to also expose our agent
to that gateway so we can
access those custom lambda tools
that were created for it.
Alright, perfect. So that's most
of the business logic there.
If I go back to our console,
we can see our PTO agent has
been successfully created.
And now I'm gonna do that last step,
which is creating that orchestrator.
- [Girish] Mm.
- [Justin] So let's go ahead
and say, "Create an HR orchestrator
that can delegate tasks
to the expense agent
(keyboard clicking)
and the PTO agent."
(indistinct)
Correct. Yeah, so you
could easily do that,
if you update your system prompt,
if you wanna do something
like an iteration of...
And sorry I didn't repeat the question,
but the question is could you
have a more interactive could
process of assembling the agent?
You could update your system prompt here
of the builder agent. For
the sake of the demo today,
we wanted to make it quick,
but you could absolutely
architect it that way
where you could have a
back and forth conversation
with the user so they can
help to further refine
those requirements of what
the deployed system prompt
should be, what the deployed
tools should look like,
those sorts of things.
- [Girish] Mm-hm.
- [Justin] Alright, so now
we've got our HR orchestrator,
it's configured as a client agent
and it has access to the
expense and the PTO agent.
So let's go ahead and
give that a quick test.
We'll find our HR
orchestrator, and we'll ask it,
"What agents can you communicate with?"
(keyboard clicking continues)
So what this is doing under the hood
is it's using some of the
included A2A client tools
to do a discovery and see
which agents it can connect to.
And we're expecting here to be
able to see the expense agent
and the PTO agent. So if I scroll up,
we can see, we can
communicate with two agents
and then I can ask that same
question from before of,
you know, what is user001's expenses,
or actually we'll ask
it something different.
Let's say, you know, add
an expense for user001
(keyboard clicking)
for coffee at Starbucks on
December 2nd, 2025, for breakfast
for $15.65.
All right, perfect.
And we'll give this a
minute or two to run.
This does take a bit longer
than interacting directly
with the expense agent because
first the orchestrator,
in this case, that we're
talking to, has to identify
which agent should handle this request
and then actually send a message
to that agent to allow it
to make this post command
to our data store.
So I'll just quickly show
what's going on in terms of
what was created here. So
I go back to our console.
Lemme just refresh the page quickly.
- [Attendee 6] How is the
orchestrator determining
the function supported by
each of the individual agents?
Is it inferring based on...
- [Justin] Yeah, so I did
gloss over that detail. So the question is
how can the orchestrator determine
the functionality of the agents
that it can communicate to
over A2A, so part of A2A, and
we didn't touch on this today
specifically, is what's
called an agent card.
And so those server
agents that are deployed
are advertising what's
called like an agent card
and that contains a
description of what they can do
and some of their tools, right?
So you could include those
details in the agent card.
So when the client's
discovering it's like,
"Okay, this is my expense agent,
this is what it can do, et cetera."
- [Attendee 6] Are those
parts created as part
of the agent factory or
is this something that...
- [Girish] Mm-hm.
- [Justin] Yeah,
we are creating those as
part of the agent factory.
I think I may have
scrolled over that code,
but you'll have it in the
code repository. Yeah.
Okay, cool. So now we've
got our expenses gateway
with our get-expenses
and add-expenses tools.
And then if I go back
here we can see, hey,
we've recorded this expense
and then if I were to say,
"Hey, what are user001's
expenses, we would expect
to see this as well."
- [Girish] So we have one
more question here, Justin,
go ahead.
(indistinct)
Yeah, so the question
is, in terms of managing
what permissions the agent
has to read the Dynamo table,
can it read, can it write,
how can one manage those permissions?
- [Justin] Yeah, that's a great question.
So a lot of that's gonna be
done with agent identity,
AgentCore Identity.
We didn't plug that into
our agent factory for today.
We're just using generic IM permissions.
So you can kind of query user
one, user two, user three,
and all those queries
are gonna go through.
But absolutely if like
in a production system,
if you were really deploy
this for your end users,
you would wanna use things like J. tokens
and things like that to identify
the claims of the token,
who's interacting with the agent
and then pass that through.
So they're only accessing the resources...
- [Girish] Hmm.
- [Justin] They should be able to.
- [Girish] Yeah, we
have one more question.
Sorry I couldn't get to you
earlier. Please go ahead.
(indistinct)
Okay.
Yeah, so the question is like,
are we using the same model
for generating code as well
as talking to the agent?
So in this case, what we
are doing is we have used
Sonnet 4.5 for creating agents,
and when we are talking to an agent
that is Haiku 4.5, Sonnet Haiku 4.5.
So we are using Claude models here.
(indistinct)
Correct. So in...
Mm-hm, so when two agents
are talking to each other,
like what is the security aspect of it?
So we are relying on A2A
as the underlying protocol.
So it is ensuring that the
agents can identify each other,
know what they're capable of,
and they are using the A2A protocol
to communicate with each other.
So the communication would be encrypted.
Like it'll basically use
that protocol as the channel
to communicate with each other,
the communication channel.
- [Justin] All right.
We'll take some questions
here at the end. Just we're
almost done with time here.
So just last thing I wanted to touch on is
we've got some resources. The
code repo that Girish and I
used today is that far left link.
So if you wanna play around
with that, feel free.
And then we also have like
a Strands Agent starter,
and an AgentCore samples
GitHub repository as well
that you can pull down.
And then last thing we wanna
say is just thank you all
for coming out and attending this session.
We hope you found it
valuable. Thank you all.
(people applauding)
- [Girish] Thank you all.